thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
live from kieve tonight our top story
two presidents two narratives over the
war in Ukraine as Putin claims the West
started the conflict while Biden hails
its Iron Will please stand strong
he stands proud
he stands tall
and most important it stands free
[Music]
and does the president speak we see the
front line battle as each side fights
for Advantage in eastern Ukraine
[Music]
this can use it 10 tonight the NHS
nurses pulling back from the brink
pausing their most serious strike action
yet for new discussions on pay
we see the fear that's returned for
turkey's earthquake victims after two
more dangerous tremors
the supermarket shortage of fresh
vegetables and fruit and the warning
that high energy bills are pricing out
British food
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening from Kiev we heard two very
different stories of the war in Ukraine
today as this country and the world
prepares to mark one year since Russia's
Invasion it has featured in Poland
President Biden presented a picture of
democratic allies United in support of
the people here and gaining in strength
in Moscow however President Putin blamed
the West for the war and suspended his
country's involvement in a key nuclear
treaty
tonight we'll hear from our
correspondents across this region Diana
magnet in Moscow reports on President
Putin our International Affairs editor
Dominic waghorn he's in Warsaw where
President Biden spoke and a little later
we'll hear from our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes on the front line
near bakmut in the donbass region first
tonight Diana magnes report
[Applause]
for his state of the nation address
President Putin returned to a well-worn
theme the villainy of the West and his
supposed inability to do anything other
than invade Ukraine
foreign
[Applause]
seats some in the audience not quite as
alert as others
as the front line Fight Continues to
extract its terrible toll the president
claimed ukrainians were prepared by the
West for
slaughtered material
one piece of news saved right for the
end that Russia would halt its
obligations under the new Stark treaty
the last agreement still nominally in
place to stop the proliferation of
nuclear warheads
The Ripping up of the world's Arms
Control architecture has been a
two-decades-long process but this is the
final nail in the coffin even if Russia
says it's just suspending participation
in the treaty rather than withdrawing
altogether if the world's nuclear powers
are to start talking arms control again
there needs to be a lot more trust than
there is now because it's a war evgeny
pop-off was there he's a member of
Parliament and a well-known journalist
for State TV not a man horse stray from
the party line are we a peaceful country
and but we can use Force to defend our
motherland
and this message seems to resonate
certainly with those we met afterwards
[Music]
if people wanted a vision for how this
war ends they did not get one just a
speech infused with bitterness and
paranoia from the man who could end it
in a heartbeat
Donna McNeese Sky News
[Applause]
so a familiar belligerent message from
Moscow today but from President Biden in
Warsaw a very different take on the war
in his speech Putin said the Ukrainian
people are hostages of the Kiev regime
and that winning the war was a matter of
our country's existence and he
reiterated the claim that Ukraine and
the West have started the war President
Biden though placed the blame squarely
on Putin calling the war his murderous
assault on Ukraine he said it will never
be a victory for Russia and directly
disputed Putin's claims saying the West
is not plotting to attack Russia more
now on President Biden's speech from our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wagorn
we were told to expect vintage Joe Biden
and the president Drew deeply on the
past to make a heartfelt plea for
Freedom From the Past of the city where
he was standing
knowing what you stand for is most
important and knowing who stands with
you makes all the difference
the people of Poland know that you know
that
in fact you know you know it better than
anyone here in Poland because that's
what solidarity means
to the present the moment we're now in
and its importance for the future
As We Gather tonight
the world and my viewers and at an
inflection point
the decisions we make over the next five
years or so are going to determine and
shape our lives for decades to come
it's true for Americans it's true for
the people of the world
and while decisions
are ours to make now
the principles and the stakes are
eternal but he acknowledged the
challenges ahead in keeping the alliance
together one year into this war
Putin no longer doubts the strength of
our coalition
but he still doubts our conviction
he doubts our staying power
he doubts our continuous support for
Ukraine
he doubts whether NATO can remain
Unified
but there should be no doubt our support
you for Ukraine will not waver NATO will
not be divided and we will not Tire
this was Joe Biden the Statesman and
Cold War Warrior whose lifelong Battle
For Freedom had taken him all the way to
war-torn Kiev this week
Jay balance Mission now is to Rally the
Allies to maintain the unity they have
shown for a year to the surprise of many
but there are differences between them
over how fast to arm Ukraine and over
what kind of Victory they want to impose
on Russia
earlier President Biden met his polish
counterparts who want stronger support
for Ukraine he'll meet other allies
tomorrow
in Joe Biden's audience we'd found
ukrainians Julia and her mother Julia's
brother is fighting in back much she
told me the Americans had put on a
beautiful show she said but a country
needs more if it was the first day over
it will be okay today one year
I think it's not enough
too much time we wait too much time
Ukraine's government also wants more
help faster but some allies are worried
about giving too much too soon the
President's challenge is maintaining
unity and momentum as this conflict
enters another year
and Dominic is in Warsaw tonight Dominic
two very different speeches two very
different World Views
yes two leaders who are moving further
and further apart and digging in even
deeper a year into this war um if you
look at Vladimir Putin's speech it
confirmed our worst fears I think there
was this very worrying suspension of
Russia from the start nuclear arms
treaty which is really bad news for
nuclear arms control not between just
between Russia and America but also with
China as well but looking at the speech
more broadly there wasn't that
belligerent declaration of war that some
expected but there was something that I
think was probably equally worrying and
Insidious which was that Putin was kind
of normalizing what he's now saying to
the Russians is almost a sense of
permanent War he's saying to the
oligarchs get used to the idea we've
split up we've severed our ties with the
West we can do that because we've
weathered the uh the sanctions that the
West has imposed on us to the Russians
generally he's saying we are now on our
own and effectively this is now a
normalized permanent state of War it
might suit him politically really bad
for Russia but I think it's a huge
challenge for the West because if if we
have a sort of permanent state of along
long sustained period of War it's going
to be really hard for the West to hold
its unity in solidarity together if you
look at Joe Biden's speech he gave a
very clear-eyed passionate assessment of
what it is to fight for Freedom he says
that it takes more than a day takes more
than a year and he says it's always
difficult and he what he's saying to the
West is that we are in this for the long
run as well so there's no sign of a
diplomatic solution to this war which
means what happens in the military
offensives and the preparation for those
offensives is even more important
yeah okay uh Dominic thank you very much
indeed
well on Ukraine's Eastern front lines
Russian forces are continuing to inch
forward particularly around the city of
bakmut uh the ukrainians are fighting
back with the help of arms provided by
their allies in Europe and the us as our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes discovered in the donbass
anian Soldier
Soldier can round s from a French mortar
a team effort against a common enemy
at any moment Russian Artillery near the
Frontline city of bakmut could hit back
it just fired the guns now we have to
keep low not to give the location away
the Russian line is five kilometers from
here
fierce battle is Raging on this freezing
front line
as Russia ramps up its attacks
we joined soldiers from Ukraine's third
Brigade in trenches that have turned
Fields into makeshift fortresses over
the past year
is
this is what they're fighting to stop a
creeping Russian Advance that's spilling
over from back moot to the nearby town
of chasiveyar
evacuation teams wants more on the move
doing those too frail to flee
Nina's house was shelled four times
her daughter keeps her company
the next stop is the home of 83 year old
Maria and her husband
once in the minibus her husband offers
his hand
it's all he has left to give
up
in the Town Center other families are
waiting to escape like Svetlana and her
seven-year-old daughter
what is what is your wish what do you
want
Mira
I've spoken to the mayor he didn't want
to appear on camera but he said that the
situation here is hard but stable yet of
course there are people being evacuated
every day he said many thousands have
left there are still people here though
and the big worry is if back moot's
nearby Falls this place will be next
[Applause]
not guaranteed but these volunteers will
certainly be back to help more families
retreat
Deborah Haynes Sky News in eastern
Ukraine
there we are that's about it from us in
Kiev Anna safe to say we heard from two
presidents today well we heard from a
third tonight president zielinski here
in Kiev who said he didn't even bother
to watch President Putin's speech so uh
well there we are back to you in London
mark thank you
now for months the government has been
at loggerheads with hundreds of
thousands of public sector workers from
teachers to border staff ambulance and
train drivers tonight though a solution
to the most high profile dispute of all
with nurses in England suddenly appears
possible in a joint statement with the
government the Royal College of Nursing
said it was pausing strike action for
intensive talks overpay and improving
productivity in the Health Service a
health correspondent Ashish Joshi has
this report
Katie feels undervalued and underpaid
after 13 years as a pediatric nurse she
had had enough
and that's why Katie went on strike
now as the government and the nurses
Union the RCN prepare for breakthrough
talks she wants to know why the
government didn't negotiate sooner the
government are in control aren't they
they could have entered into
negotiations at any point in this we
never wanted to strike in the first
place
the RCN stepped up its campaign last
week when it announced a 48-hour walkout
which would have included nurses from
emergency departments intensive care
units and Cancer Care Services that were
previously unaffected that strike action
dude start next week has now been
suspended we certainly will
um as we've always said we will put our
plans on the table they can put their
plans on the table but I'm confident
that we will come out with a therapy
settlement for our nursing staff the
winter pressures that have gripped the
NHS look like they are finally easing
strikes have slowed down any progress on
record waiting times the government says
it's committed to Bringing Down that
seven million strong elective waiting
list but it can't do that with the
nurses out on strike since the
industrial action began more than a
hundred and forty thousand procedures
have had to be canceled and all of those
patients will need to be seen at some
stage next month Rishi sunak says he
will announce his NHS Workforce plans
you can't have a Workforce plan if your
Workforce is out on strike
these talks will be the first
significant development since the
strikes were announced Health leaders
are nervously optimistic this is what
we've been calling for for months so it
would be childish not not to welcome it
the door is open and we encourage the
trade unions now to be pragmatic to be
creative to try to find a solution
patients need and what nurses like Katie
want oh she's Josh he's Sky News
well our chief political correspondent
John Craig is outside the Department of
Health and Social care and John what has
shifted for this sudden breakthrough
then
well apart from the workforce plan that
Ashish mentioned in his report The
Cutting waiting list don't forget is one
of the prime minister's five priorities
he outlined at the beginning of the year
and health bosses have told him you're
not going to cut waiting Liz while
you've got half your workforce out on
strike and so that is why the government
has moved somewhat but let's not get
ahead of ourselves because there's a
suggestion that perhaps the government
might be prepared to go to five percent
well that's still way short of the 10
that Pat Cullen has suggested she might
be willing to accept now the other big
problem for the government is that all
the other trade unions are Furious
divide and rule the TUC is complaining
tonight and another thing that has
infuriated the trade unions is that in
its evidence to the pay review bodies
for next year 23 24 they're only
proposing three and a half percent are
sick jokes as unites Sharon Graham so
we're not much further forward Jillian
Keegan of the education secretary has
invited the teachers to strike for talks
but they're not minded to call off
theirs either so whilst Pat Cullen is
upbeat and confident she says we're a
long way off a resolution of these
strikes yet
John thank you
for people who have already lost so much
it seems the ultimate Injustice a family
who saw more than 80 relatives die after
the earthquakes in turkey and Syria now
unable to return to their homes after
two more Tremors well the first of the
new earthquakes measured 6.4 in
magnitude and struck near the city of
antakia in hate Province just after
eight last night three minutes later it
was followed by an Aftershock measuring
5.8 and then 31 much smaller shocks Sky
special correspondent Alex Crawford has
returned to antakia where she first
reported on the initial earthquakes more
than two weeks ago
one of the worst affected areas first
time round hit again
they must wonder what further misery is
possible for this region and the people
in it
trauma upon trauma loss and yet more
loss
the hatai mayor has urged residents not
to try returning to their homes few
structures remain intact and those
standing are dangerous
these terrifying moments came after a
fortnight of more than a thousand
tremors
and seismologists warn they'll likely be
more
the gundago family thought they still
had a family home not anymore
the latest set of earthquakes damaged
the roof Mehmet tells us left huge
cracks throughout our home and smashed
an upturned just about everything they
thought they might Salvage
[Music]
they've already suffered huge personal
losses more than 80 family members have
died or are missing
before we had hoped to go back to our
house Fatima tells us there were no
Tremors for two days but now there's
been another big one everything's
falling apart now we've lost all hope we
have none now
she takes us inside the tent they only
got three days ago they've been sleeping
in their car too scared to go anywhere
else well it's just these cushions
really this is all I managed to take
from the house
and just what I'm standing in she says
the millions who fled their homes and
ruined cities across Southern turkey now
fear for their lives in temporary
shelters
wherever they are nothing seems safe
and the aid workers who are helping them
say they need just about everything
right now
we've never witnessed a disaster this
big Jaffa says we've never seen anything
like it before
with so many millions in desperate need
now and an election which could be as
early as May the Turkish president is
facing increasing pressure over why so
many hundreds of thousands of homes
collapse so easily and how a natural
disaster became such a massive tragedy
and just how much of it could have been
averted Alex Crawford Sky News in
Antarctica
until the past two days Kate Forbes was
seen as the front runner to replace
Nicholas sturgeon as Scotland's first
Minister now that appears in doubt with
key party members turning against her
after she told Sky News having children
outside marriage is wrong according to
her faith and she would seek to avoid it
she has also questioned same-sex
marriage and Scotland's gender
recognition Bill she spoke to our
Scotland correspondent connellis
Kate hi nice to meet you Connor from
Skye she is the one wanting to film
Nicola sturgeon's shoes
um an eventful 24 hours the women in
charge of the country's finances The
Devout Christian who would have voted
against equal marriage
has your campaign gone up in Flames no
absolutely not is it correct for people
across Scotland to have children outside
of marriage um it's it's not it's
something that I would
um seek to avoid for me personally in
terms of my faith my faith would say
that children well it's there's Sexes
for for marriage and that's the approach
that I would practice but so is it in
your view wrong then for people to have
children outside of marriage that's your
view isn't it I mean you're asking me
would I impose my views on other people
yeah I'm just asking you you think it's
wrong well I think from for me it would
be wrong according to my feet grappling
with gender is another big issue the row
over the double rapist now known as Isla
Bryson caused trouble for Nicholas
sturgeon
trying to rationally individually what
I'm trying to do the first Minister who
wasn't initially clear on whether the
Predator was a man or woman a rapist
cannot be a woman and therefore my
straight answer would be the Isle of
Brighton is a man this at a time when
Hollywood had passed laws making it
easier for people to legally change the
recognized gender
I think we do need to look again at
safeguards particularly around young
people I would have been far more
supportive of it being 18 year olds so
you don't support 16 and 17 year olds is
that what you're saying I am seeing that
but that puts Kate Forbes on a collision
course with Nicholas sturgeon's view the
overall possession of the SNP the party
she wants to lead and the majority of
msps here in Hollywood it is a huge
gamble but one that she feels will pay
off how's it going good comes the use of
Scotland's current health secretary
feels his path to power is now looking
in good shape whatever the person's
personal views are or religious
convictions are that they don't
interfere with the policy or legislative
process look I'm I'm a practice Muslim I
don't make any bones but I'm proud to be
a Muslim I'm going to be fasting in
Ramadan in a few weeks uh time so far
this contest has been fought on social
issues leaving some in danger in a
campaign which is kicked off with a bang
not quite in the way the SNP had hoped
Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh
police have renewed their appeal to find
a missing couple and their baby
Constance Martin and Mark Gordon were
last seen with their newborn on the 8th
of January officers are concerned
because neither mother nor baby are
believed to have received medical
attention since the birth
now you may have noticed in the
supermarket in recent days shortages of
one of the country's favorite foods
Tomatoes today both Asda and Morrisons
Place limits on how many could be
purchased along with some other popular
fruit popular fruit and veg it's because
of a poor harvest in southern Europe and
North Africa and also the industry told
us today because of high energy prices
here our business correspondent gupri
nawan reports
the seeds are sewn but the UK's tomato
Harvest is yet to bear fruit and it's
likely to be a disappointing one this
year Rising Heating and fertilizer costs
are forcing Growers to cut production at
a time when Imports are drying up
because of poor weather at Lee Valley
one of Britain's biggest fruit and veg
nurseries Growers would usually have a
crop of tomatoes ready by now but
they've had to delay the season by two
months whether in Spain and in North
Africa there's food shortages and that's
only going to continue because we've
delayed planting so where we'd have
British produce on our shelves now
cucumbers peppers and tomatoes would
have followed it's been delayed by
another three four weeks so this is just
the start of it in the UK we produce
about half of the food we consume but
the balance is likely to tip away from
UK Growers as rising food Fuel and
fertilizer costs forced them to delay or
stop production altogether and if
Imports can't fill the Gap then empty
Supermarket shelves could become a
common occurrence go back to having
vegetables that are in season and you
know not worry about it yeah and growing
our own country we find it you know it's
going short and the price has gone
so expensive
Morrisons and Asda have already started
rationing some fresh produce limiting
purchases of tomatoes cucumbers and
lettuce to two or three per customer
but experts say consumers may have to
put up with higher prices unfortunately
we have seen inflation in food prices
we're anticipating that we'll fall as we
go through this year but I think we're
still seeing very unusually high prices
in supermarkets at the moment
food production in the UK is slumping as
the country's Reliance on Imports
increases
British Growers say they want to help
but right now they can't afford to feed
the nation
gurpreet no one Sky News
well finally well there was some good
news today over the nurses strike for
rugby fans the prospective industrial
action hangs over the Six Nations
Championship Wales postponed their squad
announcement for Saturday's match with
England following threats of a player's
strike they are in dispute with Welsh
rugby bosses overpay and a rule which
prevents most players who move abroad
from representing Wales